premier objet et il est très beau une
paire de chaussures uniques quelque
[ __ ] à mon effigie neuve jamais
porté en taille 42 je pense que c'est ma
taille 42
42 mise en chair sachez que c'est
accessible je partirai de 100 euros si
vous la portez ne serait-ce que 2
secondes c'est pas beaucoup plus de
valeur je la porterai t'inquiète pas
allez vas-y démarre
250 250 400 400 450 450
je rappelle que c'est pour les enfants
pour la dictée pour tous Castaldi c'est
ça qui a sa ligne ne donne pas de
l'oseille à des enfants plus c'est un
chèque je voudrais pas qu'il revienne un
pays
c'est pour la dictée pour tous ces
points une association 610 700 700 800
800 attention les mecs attention il y a
d'autres produits
dans un produit 800 800 4 800 que je
voulais dire 800 800 pour jetons 800
fois 810 si tu vas faire avec ça c'est
ma pointe
tu fais du 42
donc 42
tu as mis du vahiné sur payer
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
tout chocolat
810 2 fois
1110 3 fois pour tout choco
[Applaudissements]
attention deuxième objet deuxième objet
les chéris un slip
un petit boxeur
[Applaudissements]
sachez que je l'ai porté pendant des
tournois de paddle pas ça se revend très
cher
extrêmement bien sachez-le tu peux
sentir la couture
très bien ah oui on démonstration
tu vois tu vois je te manque quelque
chose
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est très important est-ce que ça sent
la lessive ou les boules
250 balles sentir 250 balles vas-y 250
balles la mise à prix 400 400 oui 450
la dictée pour tous pour des enfants
pour les fournitures scolaires alors on
est à combien 700 800 800000
mais pour le slip mais tu niques une
fois 1200
[Applaudissements]
vous avez pas faire comme la dernière
fois là il faut vraiment donner
l'oseille tu le revends donc 1500 c'est
bien 1500 fois 1500 fois
adjugé vendu Guillaume
[Applaudissements]
troisième objet
ça c'est intéressant une paire de
lunettes magnifiques qui m'a appartenu
et sachez que c'est des lunettes de
soleil qui vont permettre d'arrêter
d'être éblouis par
[Applaudissements]
elles sont magnifiques 400 euros 720
[Rires]
800 800 800 800 800 pour Matthieu
Delormeau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
attention quatrième objet magnifique
[Musique]
il est magnifique il est magnifique
c'est pour les enfants pour
l'association mise à prix 300 balles
l'odeur de vos aisselles alors
[Applaudissements]
sachez que j'ai posé mes boulistes sur
le col allez sentir allez-y ça sent le
cuir de vachette voilà merci
Gilles
650 650 Benham le veut apparemment
700 700 700 tu vas mettre
[Applaudissements]
bravo à Mathieu Delormeau bravo Mathieu
qui va mettre 1500 euros pour les
enfants battus
[Applaudissements]
et enfin en revanche j'arrête
au bureau
pour le fauteuil pour le fauteuil vous
allez au bureau
est-ce qu'il a l'odeur de votre cucul
alors mise à prix
150 balles combien de fois j'ai fait
comme ça combien de fois
non mais combien
300 300 400 400 400 400 400 500 500
500 pour le fauteuil le fauteuil qui a
très peu servi c'est lorsque j'allais au
bureau
[Applaudissements]
allez allez 700
700 700 fois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je récupère le blouson
[Rires]
trois fois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]